personal finances not
math the problem with my
money is the guy I shave with the
mathematics of becoming wealthy are
somewhere you learn them somewhere
around the sixth
grade this is not an intellect problem
this is a behavior problem if I can get
the in my mirror to behave he can
be skinny and Rich but he's got
issues and he engages in stupid people
tricks to the extent that I have
dysfunction in my relationships I'm
going to struggle to build wealth to the
extent that I have dysfunction in my
behaviors like a lack of work ethic a
lack of
Integrity uh other character issues I'm
going to struggle to build wealth